كذلك أه بن عظيم أن أراك تنظر
بالأمس أه أه كل من لبنان وإسرائيل
يعلنان أن لديهما
خسائر في صفوف المدنيين على جانبي
الضربات الحدودية مستمرة أم كما تعلم أن الحسبة
متورطة هنا سمعنا من أه
زعيم الحسبة نصر الله يوم الجمعة هناك
شعور عام بذلك  ليست هناك رغبة
في التصعيد الحقيقي هنا، لكن خذنا
عبر الإجراءات التي نراها على
الأرض وما يشيرون إليه
تجاه إلينيا. لا يبدو أن هناك
توجهًا وموقفًا وشهية
لصراع واسع النطاق ولكن بالتأكيد ما نحن عليه الآن.
الرؤية هي استمرارية وأحيانا
تبدو وكأنها
تكثيف للمبادلات عبر الحدود
الآن أمس أه قُتل
مدني إسرائيلي نتيجة إطلاق
نار واستشهد أربعة فلسطينيين كانوا
يقودون مركبة كانت
جدة وأحفادها الثلاثة الذين تتراوح
أعمارهم بين 10 و 12 سنة  و 14 الذين قتلوا
بحسب السلطات اللبنانية
في غارة جوية إسرائيلية بطائرة بدون طيار
قال الإسرائيليون إنك تعلم أن المسلحين يستخدمون
مركبات للتنقل في المنطقة من
الصعب أن نتخيل كيف كان هناك أي
مسلحين أه في تلك السيارة التي
قتل فيها أربعة مدنيين أه  اليوم أه
سمعنا من أه
الجناح العسكري لحماس مثلا يقولون أنهم
أطلقوا 16 صاروخا على إسرائيل استهدفت
بلدة نهاريا وهي
أول بلدة إسرائيلية كبيرة على
الجانب الآخر من الحدود وأيضا حسب
بيان  لقد وضعوا جنوب هيا
الآن تلك تمثل بالتأكيد
أعمق الضربات أه حتى الآن على إسرائيل لكن
ليس من الواضح على الإطلاق ما إذا كانت تلك الصواريخ
قد تم اعتراضها أه بواسطة نظام القبة الحديدية
حسبة كما خرج
وقال إنهم كانوا يستهدفون
مواقع عسكرية إسرائيلية مرة واحدة  مرة أخرى مرة أخرى
التركيز على مراقبة
الاتصالات ومعدات المراقبة
أه من الجانب الإسرائيلي وفي الواقع
سمعنا منذ فترة قليلة عدة
انفجارات كبيرة أه قادمة من
جنوبنا في اتجاه
المنطقة الحدودية وشاهد مصورنا أليساندرو
جنتيلي عدة انفجارات صادرة  الصواريخ
تأتي وتذهب أيضًا، لكنها لم
تصل بعد إلى حد
التصعيد الكبير بعد.